implemented by this executive
administration laid at the feet of
Stephen Miller that creates a tinderbox
of violence and dehumanization were hurt
people hurt people
I would like to seek unanimous consent
to submit the records of the names of 17
women I met during my trip to the border
I think one of the reasons and what has
been spoken of is that there's two
different universes and it feels like
we're speaking in in two different
worlds and one of the reasons for that I
believe is because when I when I and
when we took our tour of the border one
of the first things that we were told
was that we were not allowed to speak to
the migrants that we were not allowed to
have contact with them that we shouldn't
and this was given for reasons of quote
their safety or reasons for or for the
expediency of the tour and after we
entered and after we were asked to
surrender our cell phones at the
beginning of the tour we went in and one
of the CBP officers after that morning
it being revealed by ProPublica which I
would also seek unanimous consent to
submit to the record while it was
revealed by ProPublica a secret Facebook
group where CBP members were planning to
harm or encouraging harm of myself and
congresswoman Escobar as well as mocking
the deaths of migrant children into that
environment we walked into this facility
we were asked to surrender our phones
and be guarded by the people without a
guarantee that no one there was in that
Facebook group we went in and one of the
officers attempted to sneak a photograph
photograph of myself another of the and
other congressional members and at that
point we asked to enter one of the cells
we're allowed to speak to the women and
these are the women that we spoke to
it's their handwriting and while we are
being asked to speak only to officers we
are not getting the accounts of migrants
of their treatment of what they are
experiencing and so
when these women tell me that they were
put into a cell and that their sink was
not working and we tested the sink
ourselves and the sink was not working
and they were told to drink out of a
toilet bowl I believed them I believe
these women I believed the canker sores
that I saw in their mouths because they
were only allowed to be fed on
nutritious food I believed them when
they said they were sleeping on concrete
floors for two months I believed them
and what was worst about this mr.
chairman was the fact that there were
American flags hanging all over these
facilities that children being separated
from their parents in front of an
American flag that women were being
called these names under an American
flag we cannot allow for this
[Music]
representative green who is a medical
doctor just so he shall be okay
Thank You Reverend
I really appreciated it's good to have a
doctor in the house
and miss since I interrupted you yeah
I'll give you 30 will give me you will
give me a man to wrap it up mr. chary I
know my time I was wrapping up at that
time so I and again we have to make sure
that and over and over again we spoke to
these folks whether it was agents
whether it was HHS officials often time
they said this the thing that we need
most is not resources we need policy
change so we need to change our metering
policies we need to change our detention
policies we need to change our policies
on who we call unaccompanied and that is
one of the key areas in addition to
changing our policy on foreign on
foreign affairs on investment on being
an equal partner in Latin America and
the Western Hemisphere thank you very
much thank you very much